Ucrania y China fueron grandes
protagonistas en estas discursos
iniciales del foro económico mundial de
davos por un lado fue la propia olena
celesca la esposa del presidente Polo
dimir selensky quien entregó un mensaje
dirigido no solamente a los líderes de
reunidos en este foro sino también al
resto del mundo en el que decía que no
es posible Iniciar una transición
energética y las energías limpias Sí hay
un país con ciudades que están Ardiendo
en llamas por culpa de los misiles rusos
adicionalmente a este mensaje le
respondió directamente úrsulayer la
presidenta de la comisión europea
diciendo que este año le van a entregar
una ayuda de 18 mil millones de euros
pero también entregó odio un mensaje
bastante fuerte contra china
aseguró específicamente que este país
está subvencionando a las compañías para
que vayan a consumir energía masivamente
entorpeciendo todos los planes de
transición energética china tuvo
representación en este discurso de
apertura a través de su el Primer
Ministro hule dice Primer Ministro que
ha dicho que este año esperan retomar la
senda de crecimiento Y aunque no se
refirió directamente al discurso de
úrsulay en Sí dijo que son amigos de la
inversión extranjera y que utilizarán
todas las herramientas necesarias para
atraer